i've tried to figure out why i've become
so ill there's a variety of reasons um
some of it's associated with this
familial proclivity
for depression um no doubt
but i don't believe that it was a
consequence of
certainly not of that tour i mean and
i've always liked my whole life
since i was 25 i've gone flat out i i
like that i like to live like that you
know to work
15 or 16 hours a day flat out and
i mean i did learn how to do that i
thought and be able to sustain it and
so no my health wasn't a hundred percent
on that tour
um that was probably a pro droma for
everything that happened later but
i really don't think it had anything to
do with the tour
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
clinical psychologist
a lecturer an author and perhaps most
importantly a man who truly changed my
life for the better
dr jordan peterson welcome back to the
reuben report
it's really good to see you dave gosh uh
well we we connected for about a minute
before we started this officially and
you said boy it's been about
it's been about two years we've we've
texted a little bit it's
it's been a crazy two years it goes
without saying
so before i get into any of the the meat
of this and i want to talk obviously
about the
about the new book and everything else i
think what's on everyone's mind more
than anything is
how are you just just how are you
well i'm at home and i'm working about a
third of the time i would say
i'm working hard on my podcasts and
youtube
discussions and i can manage about two
hours of work a day
and so i'm not in the hospital and
i'm sharp again reasonably sharp again
trying to write again um planning a new
book
we'll see how that goes it's nice to be
back it's nice to be doing these
discussions i've talked to lots of
interesting people over the last couple
of months
douglas murray and herzeali
[Music]
ian oh i'm going to forget
his last name mcgillcrist
he wrote the master in the in his
emissary
so i'm working a bit and i have this new
book coming out as you mentioned and
that's coming out on the 2nd of march
so that's
ins interesting and exciting and
stressful all of those things
yeah i hope it's well received i can't
evaluate it
you know i'm too close to it to evaluate
it yeah well i have
uh no doubt that there will be plenty of
people evaluating it
and uh you've already sort of dove back
into
dealing with the media so all
that stuff is kind of coming but you
know you know obviously over the last
two years so much has happened and it
feels like we're in a different world
and everything else and you know so many
people
they they asked me about you they asked
me about our time together and the tour
and everything else
and and truly for me when people ask me
about or just when i think back to that
year i mean we did about 120 stops in
almost 20 countries
you did a bunch more that i couldn't
attend even after that
um it feels like a dream to me like that
that year it was so intense and
wonderful and magical and
sometimes stressful sometimes tiring
whatever it was but it was just
in the summation it was just wonderful
do what what do you
think back on mostly about that well it
seems like a dream to me too
you know would be that the last two
years have been mostly hospitals
for one reason or another and i suppose
it's partly dreamlike because of the
vast contrast between 2018
and then 2019 and 2020 i mean that tour
was an amazing experience
it was so positive in you know apart
from the odd press blast
um which were islands of negativity and
a sea of of
of what was positive it was it was
really something to
travel from city to city and to talk to
all those people and
yeah it was an amazing experience and
i'd certainly like to do it again if i
could gather myself together
i know tammy too had a really she
thought it was a great adventure
and i thought you know we worked well
together you and i
it was nice to have some levity
associated with all the seriousness
that's a good combination if you can
pull it off it was so nice to see
all those people who were trying to
put their lives together you know and
and such a
remarkable range of people i don't want
to use the word diverse because it's
been completely poisoned of course but
there were every sort of person in our
audiences and
and they'd all come together for
for positive reasons as far as i could
tell it sure felt that way
it was so nice to meet people too and
they were always so friendly and
welcoming yeah you know you say
i've been i've been so fortunate in the
response that i've received from people
who've
watched my youtube videos or listened to
the podcast or read the book
it's really sustained me kept me going
yeah it was great it was it was a
ridiculous experience it was
unbelievable that's it
it was unbelievable it was a ridiculous
experience do you people ask me this too
and i actually don't have a good answer
for this but it beyond just the
occasional
hit piece and the strange things the new
york times enforced monogamy thing and
the rest that
was there anything negative i mean there
was some emotional stuff that was
happening and obviously you found out
that that tammy was ill and thank god
she's better now and
and you were having sex she says hello
by the way please senator sender my love
mine and david's please do
um but beyond beyond some of that the
the hit piece stuff and and some of the
health stuff that you started to deal
with and that tammy was dealing
do you remember anything that was
negative i i truly don't
it was like every day that we went
somewhere
it was more love more people putting
their lives together and the stories
just the incredible stories that we
heard everywhere
yeah well and you know we did the meet
and greets afterwards and
and i also really liked that you know i
only had 10 to 15 seconds with each
person or couple or family whatever it
was but
that was all extremely positive too so
no
i mean i've tried to figure out why i've
become so ill there's a variety of
reasons some of it's associated with
this familial proclivity
for depression um no doubt
but i don't believe that it was a
consequence of
certainly not of that tour i mean and
i've always liked my whole life
since i was 25 i've gone flat out i i
like that i like to live like that you
know to work
15 or 16 hours a day flat out and
i mean i did learn how to do that i
thought and be able to sustain it and
so no uh my health wasn't a hundred
percent on that tour
um that was probably a pro droma for
everything that happened later but
i really don't think it had anything to
do with the tour the
now all the controversy that swirled
around me that's a different thing
that that has been extremely stressful
and i don't really know how to
calibrate that you know i watch people
on twitter
and if they say something and 20 people
mob them
that's usually enough to really set them
back on their heels and
and generally people apologize and well
make things worse often by doing that
but
it doesn't take many people to go after
you before
it has a real pronounced emotional
effect and
um you know that happened a lot
and it was somewhat i can't really
understand it exactly why it happened so
much
um and i i'm sure that had some effect
on me because when it happens now it
certainly
wallops me you know we had to run in
with the london times the sunday times
a while back and it was unbelievably
stressful two weeks because of that
because you never know
of course how the public is going to
respond either and uh
so far as i said i've been so fortunate
in
people's response to me but i thought
well maybe i've gone to the well of
public sympathy one time
too many this time you know
and it was undoubtedly a mistake
perhaps oh christ i don't know to have
talked to the sunday times
but i thought i had to talk about what
happened to me
to someone and we thought well they're
hypothetically
stayed and reliable you know and it's
it's hurtful to me to see these
institutions
become corrupted you know that i i
certainly take no pleasure in seeing
that
um it's it's appalling in fact to watch
these
these once great institutions
deteriorate into
tabloid style journalism and and deceit
so but no the tour was great dave i
thought jesus
i mean it's complicated because it also
my life got so disrupted
you know because i was a professor and i
had my clinical practice and
my writing and a business that i ran
as well and now i i'm not a professor at
the moment i'm on leave still
and i don't have my clinical practice
and so i
i'm still i'm adrift to some degree
because of that
you know because that was so much of my
life um
and then of course the tour filled that
up and then
well there's prolonged bout of illness
uh
shared you know my wife and then me i'm
just starting to come to terms with
whatever my new life looks like
i think about going back to the
university but i'm not sure i can do it
and that's very dis uh what would you
say
um i don't know how to think about the
fact that maybe i can't do it
i'm certainly not happy about it it's
important do you mean because
because of the physical rigors or just
because yeah
yeah yeah just uh i don't think my i
don't think i'm reliable enough
to to take on that responsibility admit
i don't know for sure but but i'm i'm
still very ill
yeah is that i mean i don't even know
how to ask this but i mean is there
anything else you want to address with
any of that stuff i actually don't want
to belabor the point but if there's
anything that you want to get off your
chest i know
now we'll see how it goes no i don't i
don't think so i mean
um if it comes up while we talk that's
fine but
um but no it's i'm so bored of it all
right
it's so dull and and and and appalling
that
that uh we'd better talk about virtually
anything else all right well fear not
i got a couple things there is one thing
i guess there is one thing i should
address
dave really well you know
i've been an advocate for people to put
their lives together
and of course my life has fallen apart
and so you might ask yourself
well are you aware of the irony of that
and the answer to that is well
absolutely you know it's
shameful um i feel that frequently
and then so you might say and people
tweet this out fairly regularly you know
who am i to give advice and i i suppose
that's a perfectly
relevant question i guess i've always
thought and i
said this too in the lectures during the
tour that
i don't really think that what i'm doing
is giving advice or if i am i'm also
giving it to me
you know it's not like i believe that i
have all the answers
i have answers that i've found useful
while attempting to move ahead and with
this new book i can show you
this that's what it looks like the black
counterpart to the white
book the previous book today you know i
i wrote a lot of it while i was
extremely ill
and there were some advantages to that i
think in that
i only kept that material
that i felt was reliable under
duress now i think
probably perhaps my creativity was
somewhat compromised
and so that may have impacted the book
negatively but
it made for more severe editing for
example the last chapter is
uh be grateful in spite of your
suffering
and certainly maintaining that gratitude
is something i've struggled with i think
anybody who's in pain
chronically struggles with resentment
but i know that resentment poisons
and i think that gorm of courage
and so
i stand by what i've written um
you know it's funny i would i would hear
some version of that oh you know people
would ask me when they would ask about
you
and they would say oh well he was
telling people to get their lives
together and here look what happened to
him
and and my answer was always the same
with people which is well first off
he never professed to be jesus he never
professed to be perfect you actually
and this is one of the things that i
think really helped me throughout the
tour
you would often address if you were
struggling with something
you know you from what i saw virtually
every night gave a different lecture
every night and if you were frustrated
by something on a given day
you would address it that night if
something happened with the media
or something was happening personally
and i think people
they see us in these boxes or people
that write books or whatever it is
and they think that we're supposed to be
perfect all the time probably in your
case
certainly more than mine and and it's
just not
something that i ever saw you say about
yourself well luckily
luckily and i'm i'm really stunned by
this you know i thought the other day
i'm going to make an announcement about
the book on tuesday i think that's march
2nd and i thought well what do i want to
say about it and
what i really wanted to say when i
thought about i thought really what i
want to do is
thank people because you know this
criticism has come up and i think it's a
valid criticism it's like who the hell
is he to talk about
getting his getting people's act
together i mean everyone gets ill
and you know everyone has has
periods of their life where things are
going worse than they might
normally go but people have been on on
the whole
unbelievably patient with me and so
um i'm not sure why that is i mean i
it of course i'm not sure why any of
this is i'm another another thing i
struggle with
is just trying to understand what the
hell's going on
generally speaking and why i've become
such a target for attention
you know both negative and positive um
mostly mostly positive thank god
i don't know how i could tolerate it
otherwise if you'd like to see more
honest and insightful conversations with
jordan peterson himself check out our
jordan peterson playlist which includes
every interview i've ever done with him
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist both are right
over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell